اكد رئيس الوزراء الياباني ان بلاده لا
تخطط للانضمام لعضويه حلف شمال الاطلسي
لكنه اقر ان النت يخطط لفتح مكتب اتصال في
اليابان وكان السفير الياباني لدى
الولايات المتحده قد قال ان مهمه المكتب
المرتقب ستكون تسهيل اجراء مشاورات فيلم
رات الخارجيه الصينيه ان الخطوه تثير قلق
المجتمع الدولي ودول المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كما جرت العاده ما هي
دوافع الناتو لفتح مكتب اتصال للحلف في
اليابان وفي اي سياق اقليمي وكذلك دولي
تاتي هذه الخطوه وهل تعتبر هذه خطوه
تمهيدا لانضمام طوكيو الى الحلفى مستقبلا
ام يمكن اعتباره النفي الياباني حاسما
للجدل ثم نقرا ردود الفعل الصيني ومخاوفها
من هذه الخطوه وما هي التغيرات المحتمله
التي قد تطرا على المشهد في بحر الصين وسط
ما يشهده من توترات في الفتره الاخيره ثم
ما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله الاقتراب نفوذ
الناتو من الصين على مسار علاقات بيجين
واشنطن وما مدى تاثير ذلك على السلم
العالمي وكذلك استقرار المنطقه
[موسيقى]
رغم ان في الياباني لاي خطط تقود الى
الانضمام لحلف الناتو لم تخفي الصين
توجسها المتعاظم من مظاهر التقارب
المتزايد بين الحلف وطوكيو بالنسبه
فان خطط فتح مكتب اتصال تابع في طوكيو
يطرح اسئله حول نوايا الحلف من وراء ذلك
الخارجيه الصينيه اكدت على لسان المتحدث
باسمها ان توجهات النيتو في المنطقه تشكل
تدخل في الشؤون الاقليميه على نحو يثير
مواجهه بين التكتلات القائمه فيها في
الاثناء قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني امام
برلماني بلاده لست على علم باي قرار تم
اتخاذه من قبل النيتو بشان فتح مكتب للحلف
في طوكيو
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ابدا بضيفي من طوكيو
الدكتور جونيتشي تاكسي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه ناجويا للدراسات
الدوليه سيد تكاسي لنبدا بدايه بمحاوله
فهم القرار الياباني كلام رئيس الوزراء لم
يؤكد او ينفي مساله فتحي مكتب الاتصال
تابع لحلف الاطلسي
شكرا على استاد
فانز
اليابان هي التي تتراس مجموعه السبع فكل
الدول السبعه كما تعرفون هي ضمن النت
وينبغي بهذا لليابان ان ياكلها علاقه مع
النيتو ولكن ليست
مجموعه ليست عضوا في هذا الحلف اذن وليست
ايضا شريك اليابان لها فقط علاقات و روابط
مع الدول النيتو ودول حلف الناتو وقاده
الناتو هذا كل ما في الامر اذا طوكيو
ستسمح بفتح هذا المكتب مكتبه الاتصال رغم
هذا الموقف المعلن من قبل بيجين الرافض
لهذه الخطوه
[موسيقى]
المكتب يهدي فقط
للتعاون مع النيتو
متراس لمجموعه السبع
وايضا الهدف هو ارسال امن وسلامه في منطقه
المحيط الهادي وهذا الشيء جيد بالنسبه
لليابان ان يكون لها روابط مع دول النيتو
لكن روابط سياسيه فقط ولن تكون اي علاقات
عسكريه لماذا توافق اليابان على هذه
الخطوه الان في ظل هذه اللهجه المتصاعده
سيد كاسي بينها وبين بلجين
نعم كما قلت هو فقط مكتب
للاتصال لن يكون مكانا لتنسيق اي انشطه
عسكريه على الاطلاق الهدف هو ان تكون هناك
علاقات عاديه وطبيعيه ما بين الحكومه
اليابانيه ودول النيتو
للتنسيق حول ماذا ولماذا الان
نعم لماذا لان اليابان
مجموعه السبعه
وهذا بالنسبه لهذا العام طبعا واعتقد ان
هذا الشيء جيد وايجابي بالنسبه لي اليابان
هو الهدف هو ان تكون هناك علاقه ما بين
اليابان والدول النيتو
فهمت هذه المخاوف المعبر عنها من قبل
الصين تكاسي
ون
لست متاكدا لماذا
تعارض الصين او الحكومه الصينيه فتح هذا
المكتب او اي علاقات ما بين اليابان
والنيتو ان الامر لا يعدو نطاق كونه مكتب
اتصال ليس اكثر ولا اقل ولكن الصين ترى في
هذه الخطوه بانها سوف تؤثر وتزعزع استقرار
المنطقه
لا اعتقد ذلك
بالاساس مجموعه الدول السبعه لديها رؤى
مشتركه فيما يخص دعم اوكرانيا
بكل ما يستدعي الامر على مستوى السياسي من
اجل الاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا ولهذا
فاليابان بحاجه الى علاقات قويه مع النيتو
من اجل الاستمرار في تقديم هذا الدعم
السيد كيشيده
يرى بان هذه العلاقه مع الناتو ستضر
بالصين
شكرا لك ضيفي من طوكيو
دكتوراسي وانت استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه ناجويا للدراسه الدوليه
استقبل الان ضيفي ايضا لابعاد اخرى في هذا
الملف في النقاش معنا من بيجينا الدكتور
دينغ لونج استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه الدراسات الدوليه في شنغهاي ومن
واشنطن جيم مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق لشؤون اوروبا
معك سيد لمحاوله فهم لماذا يقوم حرب
الاطلسي بهذه الخطوه بفتح هذا المكتب في
طوكيو في هذا التوقيت بالذات ما الهدف من
هذه الخطوه
اولا هو ليس امرا غير معتاد ان يكون لدى
حرف النيتو ضباط اتصال
ونقاط ارتكاز في العواصم الاخرى وهذه
طريقه متبعه منذ نهايه الحرب البارده فاذا
ما اراد الحلف ان يكون لديه فهم افضل
لمواقف دول او لتنسيق افضل يقيموا مثل هذه
المكاتب مكاتب الاتصال في هذه الحاله
اعتقد ان حلف النيتو ايضا يتطلعوا الى بعض
جوانب التوتر التي نراها في الهند الصينيه
في المحيط الهندي والمحيط الهادئ وما يحصل
في ذلك الاقليم لهذا السبب وجود مكتب
اتصال في طوكيو سوف يساعد حلفاء حلف
النيتول لتنسيق المواقف وفهم ما يدري
وبالنسبه لليابان
مكتب القدره على
التفاهم والتواصل بشكل افضل مع الحكومه
اليابانيه والشعب الياباني كلما زادت
الاتصالات وكل ما زادت النقاشات كلما زادت
الشفافيه وزادت فرص عدم الدخول في مازق
وايضا هناك امل بان هذا المكتب سيعزز
الاستقرار في تلك
اذا كان هذا المكتب مجرد مكتب اتصال كما
يقول الطرفان ما تفسير هذه المخاوف لدى
بيجين
[موسيقى]
جدا هذا دليل على ان اليابان يعني
في يعني
تمهيديه
للانضمام وايضا
تسعى ايضا الى توسيع
نطاق نفوذها
الى اسيا
بحيث تتحول
تدريجيا
فضلا من
طبيعتها مؤسسه اوروبيه بشكل اساسي ولكن
رئيس الوزراء الياباني قالها صراحه لن يتا
لدى طوكيو للانضمام للحلف وبالتالي كيف
نفسر هذا التاكيد من قبلكم انها هذه خطوه
للانضمام الى الحلف
طبعا في الوقت الحالي اليابان يعني الفرق
الصغير الموكيه يعني في البدايه
وفي يعني مستقبل البعيد يمكن ان
اليابان يمكن في النهايه
رسميا في نيتو اعتقد مبرر الوحيد ليست
هناك مبررات
وجيها
لتقرب اليابان ونيتو
المبرر الوحيد وهو استخدام في الصين
هي محاوله
الصين ومن نفوذها بس نفوذها في منطقه
جدا وسلبيه جدا احتواء الصين اسال عنها
ضيفي من واشنطن السيد
جمله مؤشرات ميدانيه تقول بان لدى الحلف
فعلا
نيه ان يتجاوز هذا البعد الاقليمي الى
حسابات استراتيجيه دوليه تحركاته باتجاه
استراليا الان الى اليابان كلها تشير هناك
تحرك ما وتوسيع لمدى الحلف الى مدى ابعد
مما هو عليه الان وبالتالي هل هذا
باعتقادك سينطلي على الصين عندما نقول ان
هذا مجرد مكتبه اتصال في طوكيو
لان زميلي في بيت يشعر بهذه او فكر بهذه
الطريقه هو وغيره الذين يشككون في هذه
الخطوه عليهم ان يدركوا ان عاده النيتو
يقيموا او يؤسسوا مكاتب اتصال في البلدان
التي لا تريد الانضمام الى الحلف اصلا
فاعوضا عن ذلك
تقام هذه المكاتب مكاتب الاتصال اذا ما
كان الحل يريد لليابان ان تنضم اليه كما
فعل مع البلدان السابقه تبدا بخواط قطوات
تقديم طلب
وما الى ذلك سواء كان الامر متعلقا باستار
استراليا او اليابان للحلف الحلف طبعا عند
لديه اتصالات وعلاقات خارج نطاق اوروبا
وحاليا لا ارى صلوا من جانب حلف النيتو
لضم اي عضو من بلدان اسيا الى عضويته
ايا كان والافضل
ننظر الى الامر على اساس انه محاوله من
جانب حلف النيتو ليفهم اكثر وبعمق اكثر ما
يدور في اليابان وفي الصين وفي غيرها وفي
هذا العصر المفترض هذا هذه محاوله لفهم
افضل وليس تمهيدا
لعضويه الرياضات اليابان لا تريدها
استراليا لا تريد النيتو لا يريدها اعضاء
اذا
فيما
بهيكل
عمليا عمليا عندما يتم تزويد استراليا
بالصفقه الاخيره هنا اعني صفقه الغواصات
النوويه
والبدء بخطوات بشكل تدريجي فيما يتعلق
باليابان حتى تصبح تحت حمايه المظله
النوويه للحلف الاطلسي اليست هذه خطوات
تدريجيه قد يتم في المستقبل كما يرى ضيفه
وهي هواجس الجانب الصيني ان تصبح فعلا كل
هذه المنطقه تحت مظله الحلف الاطلس
وبالتالي يتم تطويق الصين
لا لا لا لا لا هذا اسف حقيقه ان زميلي في
بيتين ينظر الى الامور بهذه الطريق
بالكاز يمارس نفوذه في اوروبا فالامر صعب
للغايه ان يكون في نفس الوقت له نفوذ في
اسيا ايضا هذه ليست مساله مطروح على
المائده بالنسبه
لحلف الناتو ان يمد نفوذه الى منطقه
المحيط الهادئ اسيا لكن كل ما يريده ان
تكون له عين يرى في من خلالها ما يدور في
ذلك الاقليم وان يفهم الامور في المحيط
الهندي والهادئ وكما يفهم صديقنا من الصين
فطبعا اليابان لها مواقف مخاوف استراليا
ونحن نعمل على ذلك في الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده تملك قواعد عسكريه كبيره
في الصين وفي المنطقه وفي الاونه الاخيره
ايضا اجرت اتفاقيات مع الفلبين وغيرها من
اجل انشاء قواعد في هذه المنطقه فاي عين
تحتاج حتى تضيفه من خلال هذا الاتفاق مع
طوكيو وهنا اسال ضيفي من بيجينا الدكتور
دينلونج ما دام هناك هناك اقتناع لدى
الجانب الصيني بان الحلف يسعى الى ان يجعل
اليابان تحت مظله الحلف الاطلسي ماذا
ستفعل الصين في حال ما تم تاكيد هذه
الخطوه
يعني
انتقاميه ان لا هذا في
التحركات الخطيره
ان هذه
يعني معاديه
وكذلك يعني سابقه خطيره جدا وبدايه
خطيره جدا
يعني لا يرتدعيات
قبل قليل بان هذه الخطوات الهدف منها
تطويق الصين عمليا كيف يتم ذلك ما تصور
الصيني لهذه الخطه هل لك ان تشرح
طبعا هناك يعني
[موسيقى]
سبل وطرق كثيره
مثلا
لو
اليابان اندمت الى
ولم تندم هذا ليس مهما
ان المهم يمكن
يعني تبسط
نفوذها من خلال معسكرات
عسكريه في اليابان وفي
منطقه
المحيطه العادي
اسيا
وكذلك يعني
يكونوا هناك شريط طوق امني
استراليا الفلبين يعني
حيوان
كلا الجنوبيه هذا يعني سيد
ضيق على خناق الصين الصين طبعا
ترد
تتخذ
قويه جدا
هذه الجرائط
طيب سيتم ضيفي من واشنطن اذا الموقف
الرسمي المعبر عنه من قبل بيجين ترفض هذه
الخطوه هل معنى ذلك بان حيث الاطلس سوف
يتراجع عن هذه الخطوه حتى لا يثير الصين
وبالتالي مزيد من التصعيد وتعقيد هذا
الملف ام ماذا
لا ارى اولا لم يكن هناك اي دعوه رسميه
حسب ما ارى
ربما بعد اسابيع في لقاء القمه المقبل
اليابانيين سيكونون حاضرين في تلك القمه
لكن ما نحن بحاجه اليه ان نتواصل
ونتحدث مع الصين اكثر لنطمئنهم العدم وجود
اي ما يخيف اذا ما كان هناك مكتب فيه
ثلاثه موظفين فلما يخيف ذلك بلدا مثل
الصين هذا يشبه حاله الفيل الذي يخاف من
فاره من المهم للصين ان تفهم اننا عندما
نتحدث عن قواعد في الفلبين او في استراليا
او غيرها هذا ليس حلف الناتو هذه ات
بين تلك البلدان وبين الولايات المتحده
وبلدان اخرى ثانيا ان البلدان وغيرها هي
التي طلبت علاقات دفاعيه بهذا الشكل مع
الولايات المتحده لانها خائفه من تدعيم
الصين لقوتها العسكريه لو كانت الصين لا
تفعل ذلك وعوضا عن ذلك تركز على التجاره
وتعزيز الاستقرار في الاقليم والعلاقات
الطيبه لن يكون هناك علاقات دفاعيه مع
الفلبين
الوقت
واعتذر منك وانت مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه السابق لشؤون اوروبا والتي
ادركنا الوقت وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من بيجينا
دكتور استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
الدراسات الدوليه في شانغهاي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]